ما هو العقم عند الرجال
ببساطه هو عدم القدره على الاخصاب او
احداث الحمل لدى المراه خلال فتره سنه بعد
الزواج مع الممارسه المستمره وفي الوقت
الصحيح للتبويض
اسباب العقم عند الرجال يمكن تلخيصها
باربع اسباب رئيسيه اولا خلل في الغدد
الصماء المسؤوله عن افراز الهرمونات
لتحفيز خلايا الخصيه لانتاج الحيوانات
المنوي بالاضافه الى الامراض المزمنه
المعروفه كالتهاب الكلى والكبد المزمن
والفشل السبب الثالث هو وجود خلل في خروج
السائل المنوي واخيرا الالتهابات الجنسيه
غير المعالجه وتاثيراتها على فقدان القدره
العلاجات ببساطه تعتمد على المسبب كما
ذكرنا ولكن اغلب الحالات تكون بسيطه في
بعض الحالات نكتفي باعطاء العلاجات
العشبيه
والفيتامينات والمكونات المنشطه للحيوان
المنوي في حاله وجود ضعف بسيطه في حاله
وجود خلل في الهرمونات تعطى الهرمونات
للتصليح في الحالات القصوه يكون عدد
الحيوان المنوي جدا قليل ونظار الى اجراء
الحقن المجهري
[موسيقى]